well let's take a look your intuition
may be telling you that the second rule
which is more specific should be faster
because well it's more precise but
actually the opposite is true
the first rule tells us that whenever we
encounter an h1 tag we should set the
font size to 16 pixels pretty simple the
second rule is trickier first it says
that we should match any paragraph tag
like the one we have here but then once
we find a paragraph tag we should walk
up the Dom tree and only apply this rule
if there's a div element as its parent
as a result this more specific tag
actually requires more work from the
browser oh wow
so the more specific rule is more
expensive because it has to traverse
more nodes in the Dom tree that's right
exactly that's that before you go all
crazy and rewrite all of your rules
measure first chances are selector
matching is not your performance
bottleneck so I shouldn't worry about it
well I didn't say that measure first off
to my second and speaking of measure
let's take a look at dev tools